foreign
starts this hour off in Mobile Alabama
Hi Chelsea how are you
hey Dave good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
well thank you so much for taking this
call it really means a lot to me I
actually sent this question after
watching y'all's smart conference in
Nashville a few weeks ago and it just
meant a lot that y'all reached out to
have me ask this question live so
um I guess I'll get right into it I've
been working the baby steps since 2019
I've paid off 32 000 worth of credit
card debt in my car you can never have a
car note yeah thank you hope to never
have a car note ever again
um I still owe 72 000 in student loan
debt I currently rent in Alabama
and my husband I'm married my husband
lives in Maryland and we own a house in
Maryland he works for the railroad and
he hasn't been able to find
Opportunities equivalent to what he has
right now in Maryland long story short I
lived in Maryland for five years that's
where I met him I'm a person in recovery
from substance use I moved away to get
well and then moved back closer down
south to where my son from my first
marriage is so that's why we're living
separate right now because my son is
down south
so um my question is I'm looking to get
closer to my son in Mississippi he lives
about an hour and a half away from me
and like I said I currently rent the
town that he lives in very rural and
there's not a lot of opportunities to
rent there's nothing available based on
the four calls that I've made it's like
I said a small community so my husband
and I are considering looking to
purchase a second home for me in
Mississippi near where my son is and
this would require us to go outside of
the baby steps and we're just trying to
weigh all of our options here and I feel
like I'm in a Race Against Time to spend
more time with my son while he's you
know at this stage of Life he's 12. and
right now I only get him every other
weekend in the Summers so um yeah that's
that's kind of where we're at just
trying to weigh all of our options
it sounds to me like you are trying to
do everything all at once
yeah yeah it's it's been a struggle I
mean I feel comfortable renting you know
I'd be fine to rent if I were closer to
my son no I'm not talking I'm not
talking about money I'm talking about
you're trying to do a long distance
marriage you're you're really right now
trying to do long distance parenting
yeah and you're trying to clean up your
finances and you're trying to stay sober
you're trying to do a lot of stuff all
at the same time I'm afraid all this is
going to implode on itself you're asking
a lot of you
yeah yeah it is a lot I mean it's too
much um I feel yeah I feel like you know
if if I could get in a second house and
to say to my husband and I don't combine
finances at least not now we're not
against it we just us living separate
it's just made sense for us not to put
our finances together and that may be
wrong you know maybe a second because
yeah I I appreciate that you need to be
near your 12 year old
yeah but you need to be near your
husband more
yeah
more important yeah and there's nothing
in this conversation has ever ended
this fact that you're in two different
cities I never one time have I heard you
I'll bring this to a close
everything it's almost like it was going
on forever the way you talk about it
you guys don't have a plan to land This
Plane
and that's bothering me more than
anything you're asking about I've been
married 41 years and somebody asked me
the other night how we've been married
41 years is because I told Sharon if she
leaves I'm going with her
I couldn't stand to do what you're doing
I I would be a complete wet dish rag
wimp I couldn't do it I couldn't I
couldn't make it
she said she says if she dies I'm gonna
get married remarried in about 30
minutes just because I can't make it you
know that's what she says you know and
she's right you know so I don't
understand I don't I can't get my head
around what y'all are doing
well I work from home so I'm able to see
him like we make plans to see each other
every six weeks where I stay with him
for two weeks not marriage that's a
that's a fun weekend dating opportunity
yeah this is not a good plan honey and
if you buy another house you're
cementing yourselves further apart yes
yeah well what would be the solution
like if I lived with you know having my
experience in substance use and mental
health like what would would it hurt my
son from him not to have his mom
full-time you know what I'm saying like
it's just a temporary thing that I'm
wanting to spend this time with my son
until he's grown you know well it's only
six years for the next five years yes
five to six years well then your
marriage is dust
yeah
yeah and it's it's not so much of a
marriage right now like it let me put it
this way
um I know firsthand people close to me
that I love and care about who are
married to the railroad okay
and my wife said I have to leave this
town in order to stay sober and be
mentally and physically well I don't
care what my job is I quit
I'm gonna go with her
and so right now as far as I'm concerned
he is choosing he's married to his job
more than he's married to his wife and
you're married to a 12 year old more
than your husband correct yeah and so
what you're no I would not buy a house
you guys got to solve for this he needs
to come down there and y'all buy a house
and sell the house in Maryland and until
that's done you don't buy that's what
needs to happen
um or yeah you need to go back to
Maryland and you need to spend the money
you would have spent on the house on
airline tickets to come see your boy or
more often he needs his mama well more
than he needs a stretched thin barely
hanging on barely sober mom coming to
see him
yeah yeah it's hard for me to imagine
going back to using I mean August will
be 10 years that I've been clean and
sober so I'm proud of you it's awesome
thank you thank you thank you yeah it's
hard for me to imagine
yeah but the thing is you don't want to
there's no point in creating all these
stress points that's what John's saying
about you being thin yeah yeah yeah and
you're right yeah somebody needs to give
up something here
to get a more sane life situation and
only then do you make the decision to
buy but no cementing the separated
marriage by you buying a house
uh for six years no no yeah I would make
a very clear within 90 days within 180
days we are living together some way or
another right what's that look like you
may have to deal with an ugly reality
an ugly reality where he says I'm not
leaving
and then y'all are gonna have some hard
choices to make and some hard decisions
to make but just pretending that those
hard decisions don't have to be made is
just making you both crazier and crazier
and crazier yeah
and I love I love how you want to be
there with your son and I think that
that is it is important
um and there's other ways to accomplish
it rather than buying a house and uh in
a town because you haven't been able to
find a rental but I don't even want you
buying a real I don't even want you
finding a rental I want you guys to
solve for how we're going to be together
and how we're going to serve the 12 year
old and I think it's important Dave
people call my show all the time asking
about you know what do I do how do I
deal with an anxious kid or how do I
deal with a kid that's struggling
depression the number one answer I'm
always going to tell parents
you go get well because your kids are
absorbing that stuff you go take care of
you make sure you're whole and then
Circle back and start trying to solve
your kid it almost always not always but
almost always begins to lift that child
up when Mom and Dad are whole not a 12
year old 12 year old on the planet that
doesn't look at this marriage situation
and go oh right